Iran is dismissing Israeli claims about
its former nuclear program as quote a
rehash of old allegations Israeli Prime
Minister Benjamin Netanyahu says Iran
lied about previous efforts to build
nuclear weapons
he made the charge in a primetime
address on Israeli TV less than two
weeks before a deadline for President
Trump to decide whether to pull out of
the Iran nuclear deal Iran denies having
a nuclear weapons program or denied I
should say having a nuclear weapons
program before it signed that agreement
in 2015 most of the intelligence
Netanyahu cited was from before the deal
was signed he did not present any
evidence that Iran has violated that
deal Senate Foreign Relations Committee
Chairman bob corker says the u.s. knew
about Iran's past intentions when the
nuclear deal was negotiated we knew of
the possible military dimensions of
their program up until 2003 we've all
known I mean it's like the biggest
known secret
out there relative to their previous
activities so this is really not
groundbreaking President Trump said
Israel's intelligence shows he was 100%
right to criticize the deal
he says the door is still open to
renegotiating it Ron Dermer is Israel's
ambassador to the United States he joins
us from Washington ambassador good
morning good to be with you you've heard
some of the reaction not groundbreaking
not anything new your reply
well it's certainly new senator corker
hasn't seen that information yet we gave
it to US intelligence agencies a few
weeks ago it was much of the information
that we have which is a massive amount
of information we ourselves did not know
our own intelligence agencies US
intelligence agencies didn't know that a
Secretary of State Mike Pompeo who as of
last week was the director of the CIA he
said it was new information so I'm sure
when senator corker gets that
information he will understand how new
it is and it puts together
I think this giant puzzle that we all
had of Iran's nuclear program there were
a lot of question marks about Iran's
program now we have exclamation points
that they had a military nuclear program
and they had an intention and they still
have an intention to ultimately build a
nuclear weapon but mr. ambassador it was
Israeli policy and US policy that Iran
has been consistently lying about this
weapons program and so while there is
new details and fascinating new tales
about the nature and corners and
crannies of that lie the basic fact that
that everybody knew and was operating on
the fact they were lying is is still
something everybody knew well some
people knew that they were lying not
everybody there were inspectors there
were nuclear experts who claimed as of a
few years ago that Iran really didn't
have a military nuclear program so
hopefully this will be news to them but
I'll tell you John I think what was said
before that this is not a violation of
the deal is simply wrong what this
proves conclusively is that Iran
falsified all of their reports to the
International Atomic Energy Agency which
was critical for them to move forward
with the deal in addition to that they
have taken efforts since the deal to
hide this nuclear weapons program you
know I referred to this deal what
Netanyahu
yesterday about this nuclear deal as a
smoking bomb why did I say it not just
the smoking gun because you know in the
play you see the smoking gun in the
first act and then it goes off in the
later act what you see now is Iran has
all of these files in a vault they
didn't destroy them which they could
have they could have come clean about
their program in the past what they have
is all these files in the vault so when
these nuclear restrictions are removed
they can then go to those vaults and use
it to build a nuclear arsenal that's why
this deal is so dangerous ambassador the
Iranian program to design and build
nuclear weapons was hardly a secret
that's why the President Obama went
forward with this Iranian deal the key
question that many people have this
morning do the Israelis have any
evidence that Iran is currently not in
compliance with the deal I just told you
the evidence they are actively engaged
in an effort to hide their military
nuclear program and what you said also I
would dispute as well the question is
why would Iran keep this these files
because they're going to use it in the
future now a lot of people responded to
what Netanyahu said yesterday said hey
we knew all this we knew that Iran was
lying and that's why we need these
restrictions in place that would be a
reasonable argument Nora
if these restrictions did not end but
they end in a few years they are
automatically gonna be removed in a few
years what I would hope let me just
finish this one sense what I would hope
that everybody who supported the deal
before would do today is say we need
those restrictions to never end because
Iran clearly has a desire not just to
build nuclear weapons in the past which
we knew but to build nuclear weapons in
the future because they're keeping it in
a safe for safekeeping
in the future when those restrictions
are removed but that's their stated
policy which is that if the u.s. pulls
out of the deal or the deal changes
they'll restart their nuclear program
now whether they'd call it a peaceful
program or not but that's their stated
stated policy so is that a surprise to
anybody that they would restart this
program if the deal fell apart well they
may decide to restart their program but
we're not concerned that they're going
to break out to a bomb the big danger of
the deal John and this is not something
Israel saying today it's something the
prime minister said three years ago in
Congress the greater danger is not that
he
is going to get to a single nuclear bomb
by violating the deal the biggest danger
of this deal is that they can get to an
entire nuclear arsenal by keeping the
deal when all of these restrictions are
removed and no one is talking about the
price you paid for this deal which is
the removal on the the removal of the
sanctions on on Iran sanctions that were
preventing Iran from running throughout
the Middle East and conquering countries
this is what they're doing in Iraq in
Syria in Lebanon in Yemen so this
sanction relief has actually fueled
Iran's war machine and that's why this
deal is so dangerous and that's why it's
so important for the international
community to unite now behind clear
demands that Iran fully dismantle its
nuclear program and if they don't they
should ratchet up these sanctions you
ambassador do you have 100% certainty
from this White House that President
Trump is gonna withdraw from the deal
well it's ultimately gonna be president
Trump's decision and he hasn't said what
he's going to do I think it's clear what
the direction of the policy is I think
the change today from yesterday is I
think it's likely that more of your
allies will follow ultimately his
decision because the revelations that
the Prime Minister presented yesterday
will give a bridge to those who
supported this deal to walk over to the
US side and to make clear demands on
Iran moving forward
all right ambassador Dermer thank you so
much for being with us